we are just one day away from the dawn
of a new era in space flight the spacex
falcon 9 rocket is ready to blast off
from the Kennedy Space Center in Florida
and it's due to sent to NASA astronauts
into space making the SpaceX rocket the
first private rocket first private
company overall to launch humans into
orbit we've been counting down to this
historic milestone in space exploration
in our launch America coverage and Mark
strassman is at the Kennedy Space Center
where there are I hate to say this mark
growing concerns about the weather say
it ain't so Toni unfortunately it is so
you can look at these overcast skies and
they could be the spoiler for tomorrow's
launch but whenever it happens this test
flight will be a dramatic and important
milestone in u.s. human space travel and
it will all happen on launch pad 39a
behind me the same pad that said Apollo
11 to the moon
right now the SpaceX rocket and crew
capsule it will carry two veteran NASA
astronauts Bob Behnken and Doug Hurley
they'll travel from here to the
International Space Station both our
shuttle veterans who have flown twice
before to the space station only this
time a private company will take them
and that has never been done before and
that would open a new era of commercial
space travel but one factor that neither
NASA nor SpaceX can control is the
weather there is right now a 60% chance
that conditions will be good enough to
launch tomorrow but it's not just the
weather here on site that matters
meteorologists are tracking conditions
up the East Coast and here's why if the
launch should run into a significant
issue the in-flight abort system would
propel the capsule into the Atlantic and
therefore the Seas have to be reasonably
calm if the weather is not good for a
launch tomorrow the next opportunity to
launch would be Saturday afternoon Tony
all right well whatever it happens mark
they will be blasting into the future
though duly noted they're gonna blast it
in the future in some very retro looking
uniforms and a retro looking capsule as
well very cool stuff
top to bottom mark thank you very much